おねえさんこんにちは
うがいと手洗いというのは
もっとも基本的な聖週間と言われていますけれども皆さんは
具合を毎日していますか
はいっ
うがいをしているという方は1日満開されているでしょうか
1回でしょうか2回でしょそれとも3回以上でしょう
もっともここで言うないというのは歯磨きの後に口をすすぐ
愚直10枚のことではなくて
どんどんの奥まで水を入れて
ラン竜王コスそして喉を敷かれ洗う
あの外から甘いのことです
日本では幼稚園の頃からうがいを教えられていますので風邪の予防にうがいというのは
当たり前のことになっていますが
世界を見渡すと決してそうではありません
日本でうがい薬を作っているメーカーの社長さんが販売学長のためにアメリカに行き
ました
そしていろいろなところで
うがいの説明をするんですが
あんな下品な音がすることても私たちにはできないって言われて
右岸よするやさっぱり売れなかったんだそう
アメリカに限らずお隣の中国や韓国でもそしてヨーロッパの国々でも風邪の予防に
うがいをするという発想はほとんどないようです
うがいは日本独自のユニークな衛生週間
ということで果たしてそれが本当に風邪の予防に有効なのかどうか
世界の文献を調べていましたがその有効性を証明した論文は見当たりませんでした
エビデンスがない
ならば自分たちで作ろうというわけで
うがいの課税予防効果を検証する世界初の臨床試験を行うことにしました
そのやり方はこうです
日本全国18カ所で390人のボランティアの方も協力を得ました
その390人の方を3つのグループに分けます
一つは
水でをないをするグルー
8同駅でうがいをするグループそして三つ目は特に甘いをしないグループです
この三つのグループに分かれるんですが参加者が自分の好きなグループを選ぶわけでは
ありません
くじ引きをしてもらいます
くじ引きといっても実際は封筒を引くんですがその封筒を広げると開けると
割り付けが書かれています
この割り付けコンピューターで乱数を発生して作りましたので封筒を順番に弾いても
ランダムになるんですけれども
この研究では参加者に自分で封筒を引いてもらいました
つまり自分の運命は自分で決めるという一種の演出なわけです
でこのような割り付けだんだん割付け歯
3つのグループの間で背景陰湿なは地
日頃の衛生週間ですとか健康意識ですとかそういったものを均一にする
そのための科学的な方策です
3つのグループのうち奪いをする二つのグループにはうがいのやり方も指定しました
精霊に重視しぐらいのお水もしくは
薄めたヨード液を口に含み
駆逐じゅくじゅくちょっとうがいをやりますこれ1回目ん
そして2回目は喉の奥まで入れて柄からかなかなかなからって言う
このがながら甘いをやっていただきます
そして3階には2回目と同じように臨んの多くのまで水を入れてガラガラうがいを
しっかりなくてはなります
この3回で1区
この1クールのないを1日に3回以上
そしてソロをそれを2カ月にわたって行ってもらいました
う前のやり方には色々な流儀があると思いますがここは科学研究ですからやり方を
一通りに決めます
そして
人の参加者に2カ月間にわたって白くをつけてもらいました
うがい日記です
うがい日記には
風に関数色々な症状ができされていてそのそれぞれをなし
軽い中くらい重いの4段階で評価してもらいます
これを一日に一回寝る前にその日1日を振り返って書いてもらいます
これを2ヶ月やってもらいます
最終的には3つのグループの間で風邪をひいた人の割合を比べるわけですが風邪をひい
たかどうかは自分で判断するわけではありません
この風日記の中のどの症状とどの清水が組み合わさってそれがどのくらい悪くなって何
日続いたか
こういうことを予め事前に決めておいて
そして風日記を殿へ入力して自動的に判定するわけです
これもですね
科学的に判断するできるだけ客観的な判定をするという一つの方策です
さあ結果はどうだったでしょうか
これがメインの結果です
横軸はうがいを始めたからの日数
縦軸は風邪をひいた人の割合です
うがいをしないと口にしないグルーパー黒い線のように
なってまして2カ月間でおよそ40%の人が風邪をひきました
ところが水でうがいをしますと青い線のよう
割合にして36%
多変量解析ではい研修をそろえると40%の減少というふうに計算されます
一方
ヨード液で奪いをするとどうでしょう
赤い線のようになります
なぜかうがいをしないグループとあまり変わりませんでした
風邪をひいた場合の症状についても比較してみました
水貝をしたグループでは風邪の症状がいくらか軽くなるという傾向も認められました
では
なぜ水でうがいをすると風邪をひきにくくなるのでしょうか
風邪のウィルスがうがいで洗い流されたのでしょう
風邪のウィルスというのはのどの細胞のレセプターにくっついて割と早く
待望の中に入ってしまいますので1日2回や3回うがいをやったぐらいで
これが除去されるとはちょっと考えにくいですね
じゃあなぜでしょうか
ウイルスの感染を助けるプロ tears 一種の酵素ですけれどもこれは
口の中にたまたま入ってきたある種の細菌が作ったりあるいは空気中のホコリの中にも
あったりしますがこのプロ tears
これでしたらタンパク質ですから
うがいによって比較的容易に除去することができます
ウイルスの感染を助ける物質を洗い流したんじゃないかというふうに我々は考えてい
ます
ではヨード液はなぜあまり効果がなかったのでしょうか
8同駅は非常に強力な照度ゲームです
確かに風邪の原因となるウィルスをやっつけることができますが
口の中に積みついていて
微生物世界の秩序を保っている
最近たちこれを常在細菌叢と言いますけれどもこの正常な細菌叢
これも
8同駅によって根こそぎやっつけてしまう
そのため口の中は丸裸の状態になってしまって
入って感染に弱くなったのかもしれません
もっとも我々の研究は
際にやってみたらこうだったという事を証明する研究であるので
メカニズムの言葉では説明できません
よってそちらの方は他の研究者にお任せすることにします
ところで
日本では風の医療費これが年間およそ5000億円
でその他に市販の風邪薬のマーケットが年間およそ1,000億円です
もし世の中の人がしっかりとうがいをしてくれたらこれらの経費はかなり節約できそう
ですね
経済的な面だけでなく労力の損失という面でも外は
貢献しそうです
それではここで実際にうがいをやってみましょう
色のついた皆さんにね見やすいために色の付いた水でやりますけれどもこれは水道の水
で全然構いません
60しぐらいに
そして
口に含みます
うわあああああああ
3回目4今と同じことはもう1回だけあります
あんたんですね
うがいをすると口の中がスッキリするだけでなく風邪の予防にも役立ちます
今日この話をお聞きになった方は世界のお供たちにぜひ
うがいを勧めてみてください
健康は毎日のうがいからこれが今日のテイク本命生ですどうもありがとうございました